c'est quoi ce bordel
tu te retourne pas tu t'arrêtes parcours
eduardo diconne 5e régiment de marines
je suis rentré depuis un an j'ai pas eu
une seule proposition de travail
ma femme et ma fille sont à deux états
ici quand je dis que je ferai n'importe
quel boulot madame je ne la sens pas
vous m'avez bien du salaire de base
commencer ce soir bienvenue au centre
commercial de riedisheim
tu vois cette splendeur et d attention
les yeux
[Musique]
qui va venir
il est temps que nous ayons une petite
conversation livrez-nous la petite on
vous seraient tous traquer et éliminer
gestion dernier au cas où vous n'auriez
pas remarqué vous ne pouvez pas
communiquer avec l'extérieur
tu peux me dire ce qu on fabrique on le
renvoie notre carte de visite
seigneur vous ne pourrez ni nous
empêcher d'entrer ni lui sauver la vie
j'suis sous protection policière depuis
un an trouvez moi de me protéger
c'est quoi ton plan aurait fléchi un
maximum de pertes
[Musique]